Um, man. It's cool. How I talk about all the real that's going on in the world?
Huh? Um, my, my, uh, my, my opener dude. This is, remember,
you know how I talk about my opener a lot and about how ding batty he is, bro.
This made me want to do rapid fire punches into his jock. Okay.
Burgers. Everyone knows burgers are amazing. Okay.
If you think burgers, aren't amazing,
then you got no brain and that's very obvious because burger here's the other
thing too. I fully believe burgers are a snack.
If you eat one burger and you're full, that's it, dude, you have a small tummy,
but that has got a big tummy. Okay. So when I eat one burger,
you know what I want immediately after another burger,
even if it has two patties on it, Hey, that doesn't help.
I want two burgers because a burger is a snack. Our burgers like having,
if you have one burger as like having some peanuts, if you have two burgers,
it's like a meal. Okay. Glad we figured it out.
End of discussion. Do not tweet me about it. Okay.
A burger is a snack Donesville
so if you eat one and that's it, you're a skunk. Now that's obvious.
I don't want any one burner. Okay.
So, uh, my.
Opener is always like.
I'd rather go for the chicken sandwich now.
Chicken sandwiches are great as well. However, I don't need, you know,
they're a little healthier. I feel like. So I'll eat chicken sandwiches mostly,
but of course I would always want a burger. And he was like, nah, burgers.
Aren't aren't good. I don't like burgers. I'd rather get a sandwich or whatever.
And I'm like, well, you're crazy to it.
That's annoying that you pretend not to like burgers because burgers are so
good. Do you know why? Cause burgers.
So.
This did what, like a 16 year old chick would do.
Like I used to know this girl that lost her virginity in Italy and that me off
because she got swept up in the moment. Hey, Detroit, then go to Italy.
You what I'm talking about. It's so romantic to be.
Like, well, when I was studying abroad,
I met this guy and everyone called him Ella Capitano.
And we had sex in his farmhouse and he took me on his scooter,
Detroit, then study abroad.
Um, so anyway, this guy goes to Amsterdam because he's like, dude,
what else am I going to go to? Amsterdam? Okay, cool.
His buddy was out there and took a trip to Amsterdam. My opener.
McGlynn Nochi got to Amsterdam,
ate a burger in Amsterdam. All right, fine. He says,
it's the best burger he's ever had.
Okay. Now anger level is rising.
Okay.
Cause we know burgers are very American and the best burgers are 100%
of course in America. Here's the other thing, if you don't think burgers,
the best burgers are in America. They're definitely not.
In Amsterdam.
Okay. So now I'm, but I'm listening right? That he's got an open mind.
He tries to let his anger level subside. Okay. So he's talking and he says,
yeah, I had the best program ever had an Amsterdam and I go, that's ridiculous.
But I'm still trying to keep an open mind. And he says,
and I kept eating burgers in Amsterdam. And guess what?
The burgers in Amsterdam are way better than the burgers in America.
Now I sit back and I'm very angry. Of course. And I say.
Say what you said again. And he says, all the burgers.
Are in Amsterdam. They really know how to do a burger.
And I said, oh my oh.
Dude, that's so annoying because here's why dude,
you don't eat burgers in America because you say you don't like burgers.
Then in Amsterdam, you start eating burgers and you think, whoa,
these burgers are awesome. And they're better than the ones in America.
But really all you're doing,
dude is opening your mind to burgers.
You just started eating burgers and started liking burgers. Like I told you,
you like burgers. Like I said, dude, no mother.
You don't like Amsterdam burgers. You just like burgers.
Dude burgers are the. No matter where you go, dude, what are you talking about?
This guy's over in Amsterdam, eating burgers. Just like,
are you kidding me? This burger is rocket Amsterdam, dude,
man, get outta here with the,
eat burgers in America.
Now he's not eating burgers in America because he thinks the burgers are good in
the Amsterdam due to what kind of lunatic lifestyle do you live in?
That's laughable, dude.
This guy's over in Amsterdam.
Just thinking he figured some out, dude.
That's insane to me. I will never.
Do that to you. I will never do that to you, mother.
I don't let my go nuts just because I'm in another country, dude.
And you don't get swept up. Do it imagine being in Paris.
And, and, and, and falling.
In love. Get the outta here. This is real life, dude.
It ain't romantic. It's real life.
You still got to go to target and Costco and.
You're not Jerry Maguire. That movie ended early.
He got fat afterwards.
Come on, dude. The romantic burgers in Amsterdam
be you. That's what I'm saying. You need to come to a seminar for me.
Caroline Calloway. And I'll do it for free dude.
this Jared Leto thinking. He's got a cult. This is real life.
We don't mention Jared Leto on this podcast.
I've decided that actually I decided that today and I said his name and it's
fine. And people are tweeting.
Me all. Jared little really has a real call, dude, are you,
this is a real call.
And we get it and he stays drinking iced Americano.